I live in the quarterback film room at 1  Gillette Stadium my name is Tom Brady  I'm 40 years old I believe in taking  care of myself  Canha self branded diet and achieving  sustained peak performance in the  morning if my face is a little puffy  I'll put on an ice pack modified with my  $200 smartphone app that combines vague  inspirational quotes with brain games  meant for old people I'll then apply  anti-aging organic I black made from the  ashes of Jimmy Garoppolo contract  extension Gisele was wrong one day I  will throw and catch the babe I work in  the National Football League let's see  Rodgers car oh my God look at that  subtle mobility Tom are you okay I have  all the characteristics of a human being  but not a single clear identifiable  emotion I figure floors covered with the  new favors of your Super Bowl bosses  besides kill to hell